So this lecture is for facilitators and coaches, sometimes called the instructors or mentors.
Why you're here is I'm just going to go through a brief explanation
of what it is you're doing while the students are watching the lectures
and working on their presentations and getting out of the building and presenting.
What do you do?
My suggestion is to get us all aligned,
rather than me have to repeat all of the lectures we're giving the students,
is you need to go watch Lecture 0, Lecture 1, Lecture 1.5
and find your copy of the Lean LaunchPad Educators Guide.
That's kind of your prep work for the rest of this conversation.
This might take an hour or 2 to watch all these lectures
and kind of get up to speed on the material, but it's well worth your time.
Also, if you don't have a copy, please get a copy of Alexander Osterwalder's
Business Model Generation book and a copy of The Startup Owner's Manual.